I remember walking out of the office and looking through a little clearing over on the next block,
which was right in front of the Monroe Street address and seeing a lot of police cars over there.
And at that time, Bible Russ came to the office, so he had just come from over there,
or maybe the coroner's office. In any case, we walked back over there and we both were
speechless. We just walked through the house and saw where what had taken place and where he died,
and it was shocking. And then I was, you know, I just began to realize that the information
that I supplied leading up to that moment had facilitated that raid. I knew that indirectly,
I had contributed, and I felt it, and I felt bad about it. And then I got mad.
And then I had to conceal those feelings, which made it worse. I couldn't,
I couldn't say anything. I just had to continue to play the role.
FBI headquarters authorized payment of a $300 bonus to informant William O'Neill for quote,
uniquely valuable services which he rendered over the past several months. Unquote.